no so you can take this off
don't touch it uncrustable it's perfect
hi guys I'm Madeline Klein I'm Madison
Bailey I'm Carly acia Grant hey I'm
Austin North I'm Jonathan Davis I'm Drew
Starkey
's
snacks
thank you
foreign
[Music]
these are one of my favorite snacks
um ever they are Trader Joe's bomba
puffed peanut and corn snacks
what are these they're so good they're
just like nutcorns yeah they're just
like peanut butter Puffs they don't
taste like corn oh they're like sweets
they're so yummy
I could eat a bag of these at a time
it's like eating nothing
in a good way that's what I mean though
it's a little cardboard
it's like um Reese's peanut butter Puffs
but without the like GMOs and artificial
flavor there's a lot less sugar yeah you
can have my bag Maddie no I will get in
mind you're starting it they're starting
to grow they're kind of just starting to
grow on me now I rate them 10 out of 10.
I love peanut butter I love crunchy
things
okay yeah
it's been hot
topic of discussion is uh Flamin Hot
Cheetos
he's like hot hot
don't do it don't do it no spice
they're not even spiders
and Barbados though so yeah
[Music]
you're getting dewy already oh man these
are hot I'll do this I don't even know
what the spicy is that makes it spicy
it's just good how can you go wrong with
these vegetables get them in the morning
open them put two packets of hot sauce
in them shake it up and then eat them
like that these aren't hot no these are
not hot dude I'm pulling through these
this is my snack I chose popcorn
it's Timeless can't go wrong
it's like mine tastes like
I didn't get to put up the stand in here
and like make fresh buttery popcorn I
think you get the general idea so like I
guess like backstory childhood big it
was a big deal in my house to go to like
the movies when I was young my dad would
like take me out of school some days to
go see like a new movie when it came out
which I guess spread my love of movies
and acting it's like legally required
that we get a popcorn and a drink every
time we go to the totally even if we've
already eaten even if we're not hungry
we always get it just because it's
traditional well it's taking everything
in me to not just to the uncultured if
you haven't done this you know take some
of your popcorn
today
[Music]
this is my stack and I chose nerds gummy
clusters
is this anyone's first time I think it's
my first time I've never had one of
these oh
how do you feel after the whole bag
you know
don't look at the nutrition facts no
we're picking out which nerd we are oh
can I be the pink one would you like
start eating these thank you director
um I'm just getting interested we're
leading it it was many many years ago
you know it was the year 2020. there was
something called a pandemic me and my
cousin Chloe wink we're um chilling you
know watching TV and she was like you
should try these and I tried them in
that instant I fell in love so since
2020 it's our three year anniversary
and now we have them on our set at
crafty I think you added it to Austin's
list
yeah
yeah I'll take these afterwards all
right guys you're welcome okay we got
root beer wash it down this is my
childhood drink you're going on a road
trip you're stopping at the local gas
station pick up a root beer
set it straight look I'm so excited yeah
Cheers Cheers Cheers Cheers
oh man no no delicious you ate it nope
it's a little bit warm it's got to be
Frosty yes
they're the best it's delicious it's
really good you like it I love her beer
okay is that licorice it does taste like
licorice no it's uh sarsaparilla
it gives it that Sassy flavor
everyone you're welcome let's give it to
Jerome those are clutch clock I am
Frozen all right as uh as Lacey said
these are clutch o'clock
these are they're OG I mean I love
peanut butter and jelly so much PB J's
but like
also nostalgic for me Public School the
extras aisle oh yeah pay like 50 cents
for an uncrustable I would get these
maybe once a week but like when I could
it was incredible and okay if you freeze
them if you [__] freeze these
it's like a it's like the perfect like
summer snack too yeah it's sweet and
cold damn this is not good shut up
the crust is is off it's predetermined
but there is no crust it's crust
that's not a crust that's a pinch that's
like a pie pitch yeah yeah they pinched
it together no no so you can take this
off
don't touch it uncrustable it's perfect
it's like a peanut butter jelly dumpling
you don't need to I'm sorry that's the
best way thank you man yeah
foreign
thank you everybody for watching and
enjoying our snacks and here's a word
from all of my friends
season three on Netflix
period
more or less
[Music]